let's blow peter parker's minds with a
picture of Aunt May with whiplash it was
real I would really blows minor and I
would almost go bad
[Music]
spider-man homecoming so spider-man
homecoming is the third iteration of
spider-man for the big screen Tobey
Maguire with spider-man Andrew Garfield
with spider-man now Tom Holland is
spider-man all have done a fine job as
spider-man but now spider-man is part of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe he helped
out in that whole skirmish at the
airport you know back from Captain
America's Civil War and now he's like no
one and he's waiting for Tony Stark's
phone call to tell him hey you're an
Avenger we need your help a phone call
is just not coming but he wants to prove
himself as a hero all the while trying
to make it through high school because
that's spider-man and now he has a bit
of a challenge in the form of the
villain the vulture played by Michael
Keaton so now here we are new spider-man
movie but a lot about the spider-man
movie is this is a Spiderman origin
story without it being a spider-man
origin story that you've seen before is
like it is what we get it Uncle Ben he
dies Peter Parker feels responsible
great power comes great responsibility
and all that you don't get that in here
these events you know they happen but no
you don't need to see him get bit by the
radioactive spider you don't need to see
Uncle Ben die point is he's spider-man
now the origin story comes from the fact
that until now he's been getting cats
out of trees and doing small-scale stuff
now with this big blank vulture dude
he's like I got it I have to take that
guy down am I even qualified for that
[ __ ] it's like a coming-of-age story and
Tom Holland was great as Peter Parker
and spider-man he really embodied what I
loved about spider-man the cool thing
about spider-man spider-man is a kid he
should be called spider boy beware the
mask no one knows to call him as was
clearly a man right and that endearing
high school quality about him is why
people love spider-man you didn't have
to eat your green vegetables you don't
have to be Captain America yeah that's
why I love spider-man in high school and
totally speaking this movie felt like
the spider-man stories I loved when I
was younger Peter Parker's in high
school he's trying to balance his
academics and romance with yeah that
whole superhero thing and I love Tom
Halden in this role he had a taste of
him in Civil War now you get the full
meal I also love how sparingly Tony
Stark was in this movie some people were
afraid it was gonna be Iron Man for it's
not Tony Stark is a mentor role for
Peter Parker but really he's not on
screen much Peter talks about how
he wants to impress Tony Stark in
certain scenes in that Tony Stark is in
Peter Parker's mind more than he's in
your mind they use them a lot in
marketing they were like I had this
amazing spider-man to it yeah people are
kind of sick of spider-man by now maybe
but hey here's Tony Stark Ironman people
love him and watch the movie plays so
marketing wise it makes sense the
Ironman did not overstay his welcome in
this movie and Michael Keaton has the
Fulcher Man Holy Smoke
it is a Marvel Cinematic Universe movie
I'm about to gush about a villain in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe which is not
common actually kind of rare I mean he's
clearly the best spider-man villains
sent Alfred Molina as Doc Ock and
spider-man 2 in terms of Marvel
Cinematic Universe villains he's one of
the more memorable ones not only do they
start the movie out and you completely
understand where this dude's coming from
you understand you like this guy was
just a working-class dude and then he
got hosed over and he's like all right
well crime I guess I like villains like
that you feel like a lot of people could
have slipped down the path that he went
what happened to him happened to that
but Michael Keaton has an intensity
about him when it's Michael Keaton
that's when he's giant but he's in the
big mechanical vulture suit yeah he's a
big bad villain when he's out of it
needs Michael Keaton I don't think he
ever raises his voice in the movie he's
just intense
I mean 90% of this movie is about Peter
Parker and spider-man yeah I'm just
saying the parts that deal with the
vulture were great and if you're looking
for some great action this movie has
some great action scenes but spider-man
has some great rescues that he does in
the movie that you want to see in a
spider-man movie you're like dude
web-slinging let's do it have a lot of
comedy and here also there's a lot of
laughs and that comes from a spider-man
vibe spider-man should be fun it should
be funny without being a flat-out comedy
it should definitely have comedy in it
and the company comes from just a
situational circumstance and the remarks
people make these are the remarks you're
thinking as a viewer and so when they
address it you're like oh Beautiful
perfect like we're a team there's a
great movie reference in this movie and
you think of the movie reference and
then the movie addresses the fact that
yes that was a movie reference but if
you're a spider-man nut you'll notice
some characters and some names you're
like oh that's the person spider-man I
always like Easter eggs like that the
guy's spider-man homecoming was what I
was hoping spider-man homecoming would
be a great spider-man movie a great
coming-of-age movie I wanted Tom Holland
to be great as spider-man he was I want
a Michael Keaton to be great as a Joker
Joker
one of Michael Keaton to be great as the
vulture he was and they did with Michael
Keaton in the vulture what Raimi did
with Alfred Molina and Doc Ock which was
take a villain I thought was pretty
stupid and make him a pretty awesome
villain on screen it really showcased
and reminded me why I love spider-man
when I was younger and it brought the
fun back to the spider-man world couple
of great moments of heart - there is a
part in particular that just really
shows the quality of Peter Parker's
character I just love to talk about
doing a character justice in a world
where nothing spider-man will blow my
mind more than the first time I saw the
first Raimi spider-man moving because it
was just such a long wait for that movie
and when I finally saw it I was like oh
thank god spider-man homecoming is a
perfect spider-man experience for my
fellow Spidey webhead and I was a
spider-man homecoming is awesome tacular
I'm just making a rain of antagonism
here now my gosh - spider-man homecoming
have you seen it what did you think
about it or are you going to see
spider-man homecoming and what are you
hoping to say whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
wait I should be like
[Music]